it's great to welcome to the program
today for what I think will be a really
great conversation Lee McEntire who's a
research fellow at the Center for
philosophy and history of science at
Boston University he's the author of the
new book the scientific attitude
defending science from denial fraud and
pseudoscience at least so great to talk
to you today great thanks for having me
out I appreciate it so to get the
audience sort of acclimated to what
we're going to be talking about in the
book you outline that there is a sort of
denial and resistance to science as an
institution sort of above and beyond
specific topics which we can get into in
more detail later that really needs to
be met head-on and you actually proposed
in the book exactly how that should be
done let's first make the case that this
is an issue I mean for someone in the
audience who is skeptical that there is
this anti science movement how can we
explain to them that this exists well I
think it's a great question and I mean
what you have to do is to pay attention
to the fact that the the anti science or
the science denial happens in many
different areas and Eve acts climate
change denial Flat Earth is on the rise
people who deny evolution by natural
selection if you look at any one
individual case of that you might think
well it's only a few people but
cumulatively which you realize is that
the standard of reasoning around
scientific issues has really eroded in
this country and that science denial is
on the rise one of the things I've
suggested and I'm sort of open to it
being right or wrong or partially right
is that if you look at anti
intellectualism and pseudo-intellectual
ISM that pseudo-intellectual ism may
actually pose a bigger danger in the
sense that it's the difference between
those who say I don't think X really
matters at all versus those who say you
know I've looked at a little bit about
this I've read maybe in the world of
politics for example I've read some of
those pop politics books by people like
Laura Ingraham and Tucker Carlson and
therefore I now am as an
does anybody else my instinct has been
that that the latter the pseudo
intellectualism can actually be more
dangerous within the context of science
where do you think that that the truth
is on that I think you're absolutely
right
one thing that happens is a lot of
people these days have a degree from the
University of Google right they they get
on the internet and they find something
they don't know whether it's reliable or
not but after googling around or hearing
someone speak they think that they know
the facts and empirical evidence has
actually shown that it's much harder to
convince somebody who knows a little bit
about a topic than somebody who doesn't
know anything I mean that goes back to
Socrates who said that ignorance was not
as dangerous as false knowledge you know
that the people who think that they have
the right arguments they're just not
willing to listen anymore so I think
you're dead on with that is this problem
in the realm of science science
skepticism so to speak is it worse in
the United States than in other sort of
I guess we could say other countries in
general but maybe specifically worse
than another Western wealthier countries
well I mean we're number one for a lot
of these there are actually rankings on
science denial for some specific areas
it turns out that we're number two for
denial of evolution by natural selection
the country of Turkey is worse than us
they actually ban teaching evolution in
their public schools but we are
definitely number one for climate change
denial an interesting thing about that
based on the recent survey is that China
turns out to be the most enlightened
nation in the world on the subject of
climate change denial and they're the
worst polluter so that's really kind of
an interesting thing and I think shows
you that it's not just about politics
it's about reasoning strategy when you
look at the Flat Earth movement in the
United States and you know there's
debate over how much of that movement is
sort of satirical in nature but at least
some significant portion of it is not
satirical there's there's really no way
to deny that right what what do you make
of the growth of that movement well I
don't know if you know this but I went
to the Flat Earth convention in Denver
in November of 2018 yeah and there were
600 Flattr folks there and
and the first day I went incognito I
mean I bought the badge and I went
because I study science and all I wanted
to see what was up and I'm here to tell
you they were serious they were not it
was not satirical there were true
believers of plenty there were seminars
how to recruit new folks for Flat Earth
and it's a it's a growing rising
movement I think within 10 or 15 years
they're going to be Flat Earth there's
running for school board and trying to
get us to quote/unquote teach the
controversy in the public schools same
way that they're now doing for climate
change same way that happened a decade
or more ago with the evolution by
natural selection it's it's a growing
movement but they are absolutely dead
serious about this they think that they
know the truth and the rest of us have
been brainwashed one of the things that
I've experienced myself when talking
either it could be too flat earthers
could be too vaccine deniers it doesn't
really matter who is that you often
start the conversation about the merits
of the particular subject like it's a
conversation about flat earth vs.
spherical earth for example but then at
a certain point it gets into the more
general distrust or myth that comes from
a misunderstanding of what science is
and the scientific method there's often
this idea that listen science has been
wrong at the the the conclusions of
science have been wrong in the past
therefore science as a process is what
is problematic how can you start to
unwind that part because if you don't
unwind that you can't even really talk
about the subject matter yeah another
another good point I mean the the way to
handle something like that is to make
sure that you're not buying into one of
the myths of science and I think that
one of the myths of science that a lot
of science deniers buy is that science
has to prove something that science is
about certainty and in actual fact
science just not the way that science
works anytime you're trying to gather
empirical knowledge you always have the
idea that you know maybe your study can
be overthrown by some future data but
what people fail to realize is that's
not a weakness of science that's a
strength the being able to deal with and
even learn from uncertainty what
with folks who are not scientists or who
I'll say who don't want to believe in
science is that they take uncertainty as
a weakness and an opportunity to exploit
for their own views I think that this
idea about science embracing uncertainty
is really something that's endemic and
it has been for a long time what
happened recently though is that people
have stopped trusting experts about a
number of things there's a terrific book
by Tom Nichols called the death of
expertise where he talks about this it's
not just for science it's for many
different things but the effect in
science is that if people don't
understand something that a scientist
says they'll say well what do you know
I'll go look it up on Google yeah and I
think that the the problem with with a
lot of that is so on the one hand I'm
familiar with the book with and it
brilliantly brilliantly points out what
you're talking about the other problem
is that there is this thing called the
media expert industrial complex for lack
of a better term there are people who
are just kind of like partisan political
actors yeah are regularly interviewed in
media as experts when they're not so
it's sort of like their people are right
to be skeptical of individuals
identified as experts in some ways but
on the other hand it's having this this
very detrimental effect within the field
of science and I don't know how we deal
with that problem it is it is a real
problem because if you look at the way
that scientific issues are covered in
that in the media and I have to say
especially on television they often
engage in false equivalence because it's
so easy to have a split screen they'll
have somebody you know from NASA on one
side somebody with a website on the
other they'll give them equal time and
then at the end say well it's a
controversial issue you decide turning
to the audience that's not the way to
present scientific issues they often the
media because they're looking for an
angle they want to stir controversy
where there isn't one which was
disastrous for ante vats I mean look at
what the trouble that we're having now
and it's because of all the media
attention pretending that there was a
controversy where there's really not I
think the same thing happened with
climate change it's it's really
irresponsible to have that sort of false
equivalence happens all the time in the
political arena
with predictable results when it happens
with science I think you face a real
problem because the I mean the halfway
point between the truth and a lie is
still a lie can we talk a little bit
about what methods you think are
effective to kind of disabuse people of
these false notions either about science
in general or about particular issues if
you want and the way I would sort of
frame it is we know that as a general
kind of behavioral economics cognitive
psychology sort of sort of rule or
understanding that just giving people
contradictory facts to what they believe
usually backfires it often has the
effect of making people just seek more
confirmatory evidence for what they
already believe the measles outbreaks is
an interesting one where one might
imagine will hold on in growing anti
vaccine communities there are there is a
growing problem with measles outbreaks
you would think that that would get
people to re-examine their beliefs but
it doesn't really seem to work this way
well it can and I mean there were great
Studies on this and the backfire effect
and you know yes if you just Ram
evidence down people's throat but
they're not willing to hear it then
you've got a problem but there is some
other experimental evidence some studies
which have shown that that's precisely
what you should do you should make sure
that people hear the facts now if the
context in which they hear the facts is
important if you make people feel stupid
or you yell at them then they're much
less inclined to believe you but for
instance in the way that they're
handling the measles outbreak in
Washington State they're having
workshops they're sending public health
officials and physicians out to talk to
people one-on-one or in small groups and
and that seems to be working I mean if
you it's it's what I tried to model when
I went to the Flat Earth convention I
wasn't just trying to learn from them I
was trying to convince them and I can't
say that I convinced anybody but one I
weigh in with this idea you convince
people by listening to what they have to
say treating them with respect and then
gently showing them where they're wrong
just if they're willing to engage in
actual debate you should do that one
problem I think is that people have
underestimated
the growth of science denial and
scientists in particular are not willing
to have these debates they walk away
from these debates and meanwhile science
denial is growing and growing and it's
now at the level of the Senate or even
the White House and we've got a real
problem our yeah what that's one of the
things we've talked about on my program
for a while and people will regularly
call in and they'll talk about not in
this particular context but for example
with the challenging dangerous extremist
ideas when is it worth ignoring them
versus when it when is it worth actually
having conversations and and pushing
back and I don't know that in in the
political space there's a
one-size-fits-all answer what I've said
is when my assessment is that the ideas
are prevalent enough that left unchecked
they could grow out of control I want to
make an effort to challenge those ideas
but I don't know how you make that
calculus on the science side it's it's
tough I mean if you're having a values
debate you you probably can't convince
somebody you'd like to think that if it
were an empirical debate that eventually
people will you know that you could make
some progress on something like this and
so I mean it is it is probably more
difficult in the political arena that it
is in the empirical arena but I mean you
do find people in the empirical arena
changing their mind I remember the story
a few years back of the mayor of Coral
Gables Florida who is a staunch
Republican four days into his mayorship
changed his mind on climate change and
is because he saw the reality of what he
was what he was dealing with so it's
it's very hard to change people's mind
but I think it's almost impossible
unless you engage them in debate and try
to control the terms of the debate that
is make it make it about facts or I'll
tell you one question that I used with
great effect at the Flat Earth
convention what evidence would it take
to convince you that you were wrong yes
the diffusability test which I was first
introduced to by by Peter Bogosian
actually but I know is something that's
been around been around for a while very
effective in my ex
is what it stopped him they couldn't
really answer it I'm not sure how much
ground I made on it but it it stopped
him in their tracks because I don't
think they'd ever heard that question
before we've been speaking at least in
part about what's in the great book by
Lee MacIntyre the scientific attitude
defending science from denial fraud and
pseudoscience Lee really a pleasure
having you on thank you so much I really
enjoyed it